National Unity is the taliban's theme
for their lawyer jurga 3 000
participants from all over the country
meeting behind closed doors not one
woman amongst them
alarm worldwide about the exclusion of
women from public life is increasing and
girls ban from school before they even
reach their teens
the girl's issue is a challenge and
needs to be solved by the government and
the government has the responsibility to
listen to The People's demands
but since the chaos of the Taliban
seizing power last August its public
face is seen by the West as differing to
reality
this is its supreme leader not a new
face the reclusive
has been in position since 2016. he's
reported to have ordered the schooling
ban himself
he talked of Afghanistan's Pride at the
Taliban Victory and accused the U.S of
using conspiracy and propaganda after
that defeat
on the streets of Kabul education for
girls is a major issue
the Islamic Emirates should try to open
the girls school so that the level of
education for both men and women should
improve like we want female doctors
teachers and nurses
in Switzerland the un's human rights
Chief appealed to the Taliban to respect
the rights of women and girls secondary
schooling for 1.2 million girls
discontinued
these are only some of the daily
experiences of women and girls in
Afghanistan
since the Taliban took power women and
girls are experiences most significant
and Rapid rollback in enjoyment of their
rights across the board in decades
and in Kabul there's anxiety about the
effects of banning access to education
since last year their mental situation
is not normal they're at home staring at
the walls they cannot do anything most
of the girls have goals dreams Ambitions
but they cannot do anything about it
beyond the education issue the U.S and
most of the International Community have
shunned the Taliban government at a time
when the humanitarian crisis is at its
height and the needs of millions of
hungry people has never been greater all
this and the struggle that's still going
on to deal with the earthquake disaster
in paktika province
Andrew Simmons Al Jazeera